And our fact in, um, you know, ancient China's, uh, like where, like, you know,
their equivalent of like Washington DC,
like the white house was called the forbidden city.
And you are not allowed into the forbidden city as a man,
unless you were a unit that's right. That's just water.
It was so many Unix actually rose to have
extreme power. Yeah. And, uh, and a lot of those dynasties,
what a lot of Chinese.
Families would do back in the day is because the only way to get into the
forbidden city and really get like an audience with the emperor at that time,
if they needed something, if they had like a beef,
they would take one of their sons and castrate them and cut their own balls off
with a hope that they would one day be allowed into the forbidden city and get
an audience with the emperor and then be able to tell the emperor to do,
you know, to, to, to help the family of the castrated.
Boy out. So yeah,
get revenge on whoever wrong them and get rid because now their Unix son has
power and has the emperor's ear and he tells the emperor, Hey,
we got to take out this landlord.
And really it's just the father who castrated his son, sent that son into the,
to the emperor's house with the hopes that one day that kid would have enough
power with his position.
So close to the emperor to get revenge on whoever wrong that family.
There is actually a famous uniq who we will get to who did that. Uh,
but it ended up, he never really, he, it didn't work out.
He didn't actually ever get revenge because as soon as he got made it to the,
uh, to get to the emperor that emperor passed away and so on. And so, yeah,
well.
That, well that, well, you just, you don't have to get to it.
You just told the story. I just told the story. I told a story and I mean,
you know what? The Chinese names are really hard to remember.
I'll be honest with you. I think they should do in history.
They should do like they do here. Well,
I will tell you that English names in my mind.
Steve Lee. Well,
I will tell you his name was we chalk Zhang and Shaw that's w
E I Z H O N G is X I a N
give.
Do you want to give that a whirl? The real pronunciation.
Is there. Is there, if you type that into Google translate,
will they tell us the actual printed pronunciation? If I spell it out?
So let me, you give it a shot. You give it a shot,
then I'll give it a shot and we'll see what the actual one is. Okay.
So his name Zach,
his first name is w E I last name Z
H O N G Y is your nosy. H has nailed it.
Where's y'all Z,
Z H Z H O Z H O N
G X I a N. Yeah.
Wayne John. There we go. Let's see what, how you where's young Jane.
I'm going to say where's your where's young Jane.
Where's Desmond say where's yours. Yang. Let's see.
How do I pronounce things Chinese. Right? He has speaker Johnny. Let's see
pronunciation. How to pronounce Kiwi.
Yeah. Katelyn pronunciation is fine.
Would neither one of us were raised on [inaudible] try again.
Where's your son.
[Inaudible].
One more what'd you see on
[inaudible] may there's no M there, try that.
Try the Chinese Hong Kong pronunciation.
I try the Chinese China pronunciation.
None of them work except for the Cadillac. Yeah,
I guess what's the Danish pronunciation. Wow.
Way song. She ain't in. Wow. Where's he's on, she had half in Veeva
way song. She ain't in.
We may be the first people of all 8 billion people on our planet to ever try to
get the Dana's pronunciation of ways. Yoshi.
On how about the Taiwan? How about the China pronunciation?
Can't get it. You know, what's wild. Don't do they,
are they aware.
Of how complicated and hard it is to remember those names? Uh, Steve or Joe.
Is a lot easier than where's your gene. Yeah. Well, I mean,
they change their names a lot. [inaudible]
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] where's young Sharon, so.
You kind of nailed that one way. And so, anyway.
That was, that was an unfortunate, we.
May need to keep that and put that on just out of nowhere as one,
on one more of our, our plugs. Yeah.
That should be in like the opening, like montage of herself. Um,
yes. So unfortunately for that kid, you know, he cut his,
because his piece off his father cut his father cut his piece off because his
father had beef with his neighbors. And then unfortunately the emperor,
after three weeks into his surge, after he woke up, uh, the emperor died.
So yeah, the new emperor didn't care.
The cat made it all the way to the emperor's side, uh, to be as advisor.
And then the emperor died. So that kid, uh, he never got revenge for his family.
What are.
You going to do? You know, that's a chance.
Sometimes you swing and you miss because you win some, you lose some, but.
That's hilarious that that's hilarious.
That that's how brutal history was that a father was like, you know what?
To get revenge on this beef. I have,
I'm going to cut my son's balls off in the hopes that maybe he will be
picked to be an advisor to the most powerful man in this region.
What a wild thing. That's not really a good dad like that.
Kid's going to have a lot of issues that therapy will not be able to solve.
Yeah. Like my going to walk in and be like, I have some issues with my dad.
He cut my nuts out.
Yet. Well, here's the thing. My dad, I told you,
I've told you guys on podcasts before was a compulsive gambler and still is a
compulsive gambler. And did unfortunately bet $800,
which was pretty close to my mom's life savings at the time on my gender,
he bet $800 and paid up to his friends that I was going to have a vagina.
And I did in fact, come up with a Dick and balls,
but at least my dad did not turn around and cut my balls off immediately to win
the bet. Hold on, hold on.
You got to have that ready. That's good. We're going to have that for future.
Wait, joke.
Shang, go make sure you rate, review us, subscribe,
turn on your notifications. Get jiggy with it and go.
To patron.com/bay Ridge boys, where things get really wild.